I'm sorry free lost my dad was proud of
you it's game like life requires
forethought no I don't think your father
left this for you and you all know
Lauren we have all made mistakes this
was mine the answer lies buried near
Fort the truth who are you my name is
Morgan Warner it's my life after all
these years
what do you mean years your dad left me
to you that's quite the inheritance is
everything okay
Morgan Warner you ring a bell we met so
many people a lawyer a banker and a
politician quite the family does any
daughter really know her father he was a
bad husband July and a worse father are
you a good person Lauren that's what a
good person would do
it was my dad hiding nothing that can
harm you are you okay I'm fine
must have been hard trying to please him
rebel against them at the same time no
more games
what happened between you and my dad
you will know the truth this family
can't afford to make the slightest
mistake you and Dad would mind me you
say stop asking questions you don't want
answers to him family comes first
why do you have any of this this
irregularity
[Music]
I want my freedom Lauren
you